it's something that I'm known by it's on
our tapes called choosing your future
that says simply this that if you want a
thing bad enough to go out and fight for
it to work day and night for it to give
up your time your peace and your sleep
for it if all that you dream and scheme
is about it and life seems useless and
worthless without it and if you gladly
sweat for it and fret for it and plan
for it and lose all your Terror of the
opposition for it and if you simp go
after that thing that you want with all
of your capacity strength and sagacity
faith hope and confidence and Stern
pertinacity if neither cold poverty
famish or Gul sickness or pain or body
and brain can keep you away from the
thing that you want if dark it and Grim
you besiege and beset it with the help
of God you'll get it